مونيا الاقتصاد العالمي هذا العام باسوا
معدل نموم اقتصاديا منذ حوالي 21 عاما
وذلك بسبب عوامل في مقدمتها حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا التي تسببت في قفزات قياسيه في
اسعار الطاقه والغذاء معدلات التضخم في
العالم بلغت اعلى مستوياتها في 40 عاما ما
دفع البنوك المركزيه الكبرى الى رفع اسعار
الفائده عده مرات ما تسبب في تهاوي قيمه
العديد من العملات الرئيسيه امام الدولار
الامريكي بشكل لم يسبق له مثيل منذ عقدين
وامام شبح الركود توقع صندوق النقد الدولي
ان يتهاون معدل نمو الاقتصاد العالمي خلال
العام الجاري الى ثلاثه وعشرين في المئه
مقابل لنمو بلغ سته في المئه العام الماضي
اكثر من ذلك توقع صندوق ان يتراجع معدل
نمو خلال العام المقبل الى 72% وفي مؤشر
اخر قفز معدل التضخم العالمي خلال العام
الجاري الى
و18% مقارنه مع
74% العام الماضي
وقد حذر صندوق النقد الدولي من تفاقم
فقاعه الديون العالميه حيث قفزت تلك
الديون الى اكثر من 300 مليون دولار في
منتصف العام الجاري اي ما يعادل 350 في
المئه من اجمالي الناتج العالمي وحتى
الدول العربيه قفزت ديونها الى تريليون
ونصف تريليون دولار لتعادل هذه الديون 94%
من اجمالي ناتج العربيه كما كشفت بلومبرج
ان الاسهم العالميه خسرت نحو ثلاثه عشره
مليون دولار من قيمتها السوقيه خلال
الاشهر السته الاولى من العام الجاري
السواد الاعظم من تلك الخسائر تكبدته
الاسهم الامريكيه التي خسرت حوالي تسعه
ليونات دولار وهو الاداء الاسوء لها منذ
عام 2008 ياتي ذلك في الوقت الذي اعلنت
فيه الامم المتحده ان العالم يبتعد اكثر
فاكثر عن تحقيق هدفه المتمثل في القضاء
على الجوع وذلك وسط تفاقم اشكاليه انعدام
الامن الغذائي وسوء التغذيه بجميع اشكاله
وذلك عام 2030
واعلنت الامم المتحده ان عدد الاشخاص
الذين يعانون من الجوع في العالم ارتفع
الى حوالي
828 مليون شخص اي بزياده قدرها نحو 46
مليون شخص اكثر من ذلك كشفت منظمه الامم
المتحده للاغذيه والزراعه الفاو ان عدد
الجيع في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا بلغ تسعه وستين مليون شخص ولا
تخفي المؤسسات الماليه الدوليه نظرتها
التشاؤميه للاقتصاد في العام المقبل الذي
يرى صندوق النقد ان افاق الاقتصاد العالمي
تبدو اكثر كابه مما هي عليه وسط تصاعد
المخاطر من دخول عديد الاقتصادات في ركود
خلال العام المقبل